[Music]
audiences fell in love with nightcourt's
wacky portrayal of a manhattan courtroom
whether it's the history of the jazzy
theme songs celebrity guest stars or the
cast of misfits that make up the
ensemble this is everything you never
knew about the beloved sitcom
a magician and comedian the late harry
anderson appeared on saturday night live
and guest starred on cheers as con man
harry the hat before landing on the
bench at night court
as judge harold harry t stone anderson
is the moral center of the show with a
screwball sense of humor and a love of
magic tricks classic films and the music
of mel tormey
a relatively young jurist in his 30s
harry lands a gig out of hundreds of
candidates because he happened to be
home on a sunday to answer the mayor's
call
as he explains in the pilot all you need
is love in the show's finale he receives
an offer to tour with tormey who by then
had made
several guest appearances on night court
in addition to judge stone anderson who
died in 2018
played humorous columnist dave berry in
the 1990s sitcom dave's world and the
adult richie tozer in the 1990 tv
adaptation of stephen king's it
prosecutor dan fielding rarely shows
compassion although he occasionally
surprises those around him when he does
actor john larroquette's ride demeanor
and dry delivery kept dan from being a
one note lech
partly because the scripts know and dan
is more pathetic than smooth
your honor circumstances of a very
extremely urgent personal nature have
risen and regrettably forced me to ask
for a recess
sex or money dan lara cat who made his
film debut providing the opening
narration of 1974's the texas chainsaw
massacre has popped up on other series
since night court ended
most notably the comedy drama boston
legal and the fantasy adventure series
the librarians
marky post wasn't the first public
defender on night court but she played
the role the longest as christine
sullivan from
seasons three to nine a perpetual foil
for dan's advances and a romantic
interest for harry christine is smart
witty and amusingly flustered thanks to
post-comic timing
much like harry idolizes mel tormey
christine too has a quirk
she adores the royal family and princess
diana collecting memorabilia such as
porcelain thimbles
christine is honest to a fault although
she does flash a guy to help harry win
an arm wrestling contest
she becomes disillusioned and considers
quitting her job soon after arriving in
season three when a man
mugs her but when the same mugger winds
up taking hostages at the courthouse
christine rediscovers her compassion and
helps save the day
the series n sees the impassioned and
creative defense attorney off to
congress
b-movie veteran richard mole had shaved
his head for a role when he auditioned
for night court
the producers liked the bald look so
much on the six foot seven inch mole
that they asked him to keep that style
for bailiff nostradamus bull shannon
bull is fiercely protective of harry and
can seem dim-witted at times
although mold played this with a gentle
and child-like nature bull's towering
size means that he often wrangles rowdy
defendants
something that makes him consider a
wrestling promoter's job offer in season
2
after he corrals guest star lou ferrigno
fortunately harry and the others
convince him to return to the courthouse
instead of pursuing a career in the ring
and probably the end of nightcourt sees
aliens whisk bull off to jupiter so he
can help short aliens reach things on
high shelves
since then mole has appeared in but i'm
a cheerleader and scary movie 2.
he's also voiced various animated
villains including two-face and batman
the animated series
scorpion and spider-man the animated
series and the abomination in the
incredible hulk
accompanying bull as the older and wiser
bailiff on night courts are three women
scattered throughout the show's tenure
the deadpan's selma diamond played
bailiff selma hacker in seasons 1 and 2
earning golden globe and emmy
nominations sadly diamond died of cancer
in 1985.
her replacement florence hallett played
flo kleiner during season 3
until she too died of cancer in 1986.
enter
marsha warfield who had made her comedic
debut as part of richard pryor's tv
sketch show in 1977.
her rosalind roz russell has a
no-nonsense demeanor at first
barraz also has a caring side after she
becomes involved
with christine's handsome pen pal in
season six played by a pre-24 dennis
haysberg she's floored to learn that the
man is an escaped prisoner
roz sees him sent back behind bars
although bull gives her a chance to say
goodbye privately
she scolds her fellow bailiff before
giving him a kiss on the head
rounding out the courtroom regulars is
clerk charles robinson who played
macintosh mack robinson in seasons two
through nine
a vietnam veteran mack is married to
quan lead duke robinson
a refugee from vietnam who becomes an
american citizen and opens a restaurant
during the show's run
typically wearing a plaid shirt cardigan
and knit tie mac is a loyal friend and
more of a straight arrow than harry
although he can also get the better of
dan with a punch line
at the end of the series mack decides to
attend film school and become a director
and what might be a nod to the real
robin since directing chops
robinson directed three episodes of
night court but he's also continued
acting appearing in the house bunny and
the tv series kia and peel
mom and this is us we can't mention
nightcore without discussing its
distinctive instrumental theme song
a bass heavy jazz tune that runs over
the opening titles and shots of the
brooklyn bridge
municipal courthouse and people mingling
around the city at night
this iconic theme is the work of
composer jack elliot who served as music
director for the andy williams show and
also co-wrote the themes to barney
miller in the 2011 charlie's angel
series
beyond his work in television he served
as the music director for the grammy
awards the academy awards the primetime
emmy awards the kennedy center honors
and the 1984
summer olympic ceremony in los angeles
nightcore's theme includes a saxophone
melody played by ernie watts a long time
studio musician
watts notably played saxon marvin gaye's
let's get it on and appears on the
soundtrack for the color purple
beyond night court astute fans might
have noticed parts of the theme appear
elsewhere in pop culture
including a family guy episode in which
former u.s president bill clinton plays
saxophone
befitting a long-running show with
various court cases night court has a
lot of guest stars one of them was brent
spiner who later shot to fame as
lieutenant commander data
a self-aware android curious about human
life on star trek the next generation on
night court spiner played bob wheeler
husband to june
they appear to be down on their luck
appalachians from west virginia but are
really from
yugoslavia when asked about why they
lied bob has the perfect explanation
i don't know it was just the first
exotic place that popped into my head
the pair appear in front of harry for
various mishaps including trying egg
farming with a propane-powered incubator
as christine explains in their defense
at one point the wheelers even run a
concession stand in the courthouse
but the star trek ties don't end there
john larrick cat appeared as the klingon
malts in 1984 star trek iii the search
for spock what's more during one
marathon caseload in season six
harry hears a case involving two star
trek fans who caused a disturbance at a
seminar discussing starfleet command
one dressed as jordy leforge from the
next generation and the other
dressed as mr spock from the original
series nearly come to blows
with a ladder threatening the former
with the vulcan death grip before bull
intervenes
night court's guest stars range from the
well-known like mel tormey to actors who
had not yet earned wider recognition
like dennis haysberg
some appear in just one episode during
his run on family ties and just before
back to the future michael j
fox dropped by night court as a
shoplifting runaway whose encounter with
another defendant who thinks he's santa
claus sets him on the right path
other one-episode guest stars include
terry hatcher who played dan's boss's
sexy niece
robert englund is a defendant charged
with arson who thinks aliens are among
us
fran drescher is a schizophrenic woman
whose personality changes leave dan
literally bound and gagged
and comedian elaine boosler is joy
harry's ironically named abrasive
assistant
others like spiner had recurring roles
comedian and actor gilbert gottfried
played a temporary prosecuting attorney
over three episodes in season nine
another comedian yakov smirnoff appears
in five episodes from 1984-1999
playing russian to vector yaakov
korolenko he first appears before harry
in season one
charged for stolen property and
threatening to burn down the courtroom
in spite of this harry takes a liking to
him later helping him search for his
brother as well as obtain a visa
extension for his father
although every episode is set during the
night shift night court might be best
known for several day in the life
episodes in which the regulars work
through a hefty docket on a deadline
reasons for these time crunches include
a burst pipe flooding the holding cells
and the staff racing to beat a federal
judge's ruling granting amnesty to
anyone not arraigned by midnight
one of these stories season 5's another
day in the life is one of the series
most popular episodes
its setup involves the texas millionaire
arrested for jumping in a park fountain
who offers to pay the mortgage of an
impoverished orphanage if the staff
hears his case by midnight
meanwhile dan has a bet with the other
prosecutors on who can convict the most
defendants by weight
the rapid fire banter and colorful case
snippets of these unique episodes
squeeze in lots of laughs
and one two defendants dispute which one
is god another time harry scolds the
pope for standing and waving while
driving
something the pontiff doesn't actually
do the judge even finds an animated wily
coyote guilty of harassing the
roadrunner
and might i add if you're hungry go to a
restaurant for criminy's sake or a
grocery store
but leave that poor bird alone
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one